[Music]
bank robberies
military compounds and spies that's what
you might think of
when it comes to data center security
and to be honest you're not
too far off but how exactly does google
reliably secure
its data centers it all starts with six
layers
also known as defense in depth layers
become progressively more protected
with access checks as you move to the
core of the data center
layers 1 and 2 involve property
boundaries vehicle crash barriers
fences with motion detection guard
kiosks and thermal cameras
layer 3 gives you access to the secure
lobby where you get your irises
scanned and we'll find the general
office area
where hardware and data center
operations teams work
you're now in the data center building
badge checks exist
at every entry point and only one person
can go through a door at a time
as you move to layer four you'll find
operational rooms
like the core network room and security
operations center
which contains a highly trained staff
that monitors
all aspects of security and can keep a
level head at all times
next is layer five the data center floor
less than one percent of googlers ever
get to set foot here
this is where data lives in order to
advance you have to walk through a
circle lock
a big glass tube that lets only one
person enter
at a time here you get your credentials
checked
and your iris is scanned this is a form
of dual factor
authentication you must present two
forms of identification
in this case a badge and biometric data
to validate an
individual's identity layer six is disk
erase
where retiring hard drives get their
data wiped and reused
or shredded and recycled only those with
special access
can enter the diska race room and
retrieve drives through a secure two-way
locker system
in order to exit layers five and six
you're required to go through full metal
detection
under the supervision of a staff member
but what about protecting from the
outside
we're talking asteroids electromagnetic
pulses
fires pandemics and zombies
we run dozens of drills a year engaging
unannounced skilled adversaries to try
to get past controls
after every testing attempt we always
evaluate our performance
to ensure the strength of our security
controls and iterate controls as needed
now that's what you call a culture of
security if you want to learn more
check out cloud.google.com security
you